HAVE THE SAME GOAL, THEY WILL
HAVE A SHOT TO PROVE IT.
>> Bret: HILLARY, THANK YOU.
THERE IS A NEW PLAYER TONIGHT,
HARD TO BELIEVE, BUT THERE IS,
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
SWEEPSTAKES.
BILLIONAIRE ACTIVIST TOM STEYER
SAYS HE WILL FIGHT WHAT HE CALLS
A HOSTILE CORPORATE TAKEOVER OF
OUR DEMOCRACY.
THIS COMES AS THE FRONT RUNNER
PUTS HIS FINANCIAL RECORDS IN
THE SPOTLIGHT.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY HAS
SPECIFICS TONIGHT FROM THE HILL.
>> THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
CALLS HIMSELF MIDDLE-CLASS JOE.
>> IN WASHINGTON, THAT'S NOT
MEANT AS A COMPONENT.
>> BUT SINCE LEAVING OFFICE
MIDDLE-CLASS JOE HAS BEEN MAKING
TOP DOLLAR.
LOOKING AND SPEAKING ENGAGEMENTS
AT UP TO A TEN AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLAR RACE BETWEEN 2016
AND 2017 AND MORE MONEY FOR THE
BITINGS AND MORE MONEY FOR
CHARITY.
9.2% OF ITS SALARY IN 2017, A
MILLION DOLLARS MORE THAN THE
1.5% OF HIS SALARY IN 2016.
THE 76-YEAR-OLD HASN'T LET GO OF
FIRST PLACE YET, BUT THE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD JUST WON'T
SHRINK BECAUSE THE DAY AFTER ONE
DROPPED OUT, ANOTHER JUMPED IN.
>> MY NAME IS TOM STEYER AND I'M
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> THE BILLIONAIRE TEASED A RUN
EARLIER THIS YEAR AND THE
PLATFORM WAS TO IMPEACH.
>> AND STRENGTHENING MY
COMMITMENT THE NEED TO IMPEACH.
>> BUT THE WORD IMPEACHMENT WAS
MISSING FROM HIS ANNOUNCEMENT
VIDEO.
>> I THINK WHAT PEOPLE BELIEVE
IS THAT THE SYSTEM HAS LEFT
THEM.
I THINK PEOPLE BELIEVE THE
CORPORATIONS HAVE BOUGHT THE
DEMOCRACY, THAT THE POLITICIANS
DON'T CARE ABOUT OR RESPECT
THEM.
>> THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN RESPONDED
"IT DOESN'T SEEM MUCH FOR THE
WHOLE DEMOCRAT FIELD THAT THE
NUMBER ONE DEMOCRAT OWNER TOOK A
LOOK AROUND AND DECIDED THAT
THERE'S NO ONE HE CAN SUPPORT."
DEMOCRATS SOUND JUST AS EXCITED.
ELIZABETH WARREN TWEETED "THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY SHOULD NOT BE
DECIDED BY BILLIONAIRES.
BERNIE SANDERS SHARES THE
SENTIMENT AND IS ALSO
DISCOUNTING JOE BIDEN'S RECENT
APOLOGY FOR PAST REMARKS ABOUT
CIVILITY WITH SEGREGATIONISTS.
>> JOE HAS TALKED ABOUT HIS
EARLY DAYS IN THE SENATE WHEN
THINGS WERE SIMPLE.
BUT UNDERNEATH THAT SO-CALLED
CIVILITY THERE WAS AN INCREDIBLE
OPPRESSION AND UGLINESS AND
ATTACKS AGAINST THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
>> BUT THE BITINGS DON'T BELIEVE
MUCH DAMAGE HAS BEEN DONE.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW
JOE BIDEN.
IF THEY KNOW HIS VALUES, THEY
KNOW WHAT HE STANDS FOR.
AND THEY DIDN'T BUY IT.
>> SOMETHING ELSE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT JOE BIDEN, HE
WAS ONCE THE POOREST MAN IN THE
SENATE.
SOMETHING HE TALKED ABOUT ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL ALL THE TIME.
IF NOW WE WAIT TO SEE IF HE
KEEPS TALKING ABOUT IT AFTER